[Music]
in that news that's it that's it some of
my iPAQ bats pack packs like backpacks
Oh anytime I see backpack people when
I'm at a target I'm like thieves Oh what
are your thoughts on the backpack purses
like a purse as a little tiny backpack
those are different that's completely
different when I see very suntan people
with backpacks I'm like your burglar
Felicity Huffman was sentenced to only
14 days in jail ah I saw this what
happened Waldman in the college cheating
scam I wish you got more this is a case
of white privilege not even that it's
[ __ ] rich ass [ __ ] Hollywood
people rich we have 14 days so this is
Felicity and Lauri the two fake
celebrity faces of the college exam
actual privilege [ __ ] yeah the ones
that are using that [ __ ] to like [ __ ]
bribe their way into colleges I wish
they got more [ __ ] time the same [ __ ]
that happen all street guys yeah okay
nothing that's why we're doing the wrong
crimes and the wrong jobs yep so she
paid $15,000 I believe nothing I wanted
to go to USC
no offense Trojans love Trojans but I'm
like come on bro like to risk your
entire [ __ ] life for us see why the
other chicken yeah Laurene for his
daughter what dude for for USC
she paid five hundred thousand that is
worse for USC can you pay her to like
Oxford what I'm saying she wanted to
stay in SoCal is that the one you guys
want to you want to UCLA you feel I mean
I mean Caltech would have been better
my brother-in-law is a UCSD teacher
which is why that shouldn't be
prestigious either felicity Cal State LA
felicity she came in pleading guilty
she took the plea deal she said she was
very apologetic got him she was just
like I should have known better
yeah you should've she owned up to her
[ __ ] and so the only sentenced her to 14
days in jail
30,000 she's required to pay $30,000 a
fur fine and do 250 hours of community
service
I wanna see her in a jumpsuit bad with
fellow cello she did what she claimed
she believed that she pleaded guilty to
one count of conspiracy and fraud as
part of the deal with prosecutors so now
Lori yes this is the buck paid so much
money for her girls right she initially
said I'm not guilty I didn't do this
[ __ ] yeah so then now she's looking back
she's looking at 40 years in prison
guilty terrible what did she be found
guilty huh
why wouldn't she be found killed her
husband her playing dumb they're like
pictures of a [ __ ] team that she
didn't even like wrong crew I thought
the judge was gonna be like I loved you
on full house
you are innocent is it I loved you in
that shitty hallmark Christmas movie are
they are actually so they're saying that
they're gonna be using like Becky Aunt
Becky why like [ __ ] don't like it's I
get it it's smart to like play to the
jury but also like [ __ ] these people
like throw the book at them yeah but you
know you know what those shoes with
Uncle Jesse that's forever by the way
forever
she should yeah I don't like how she's
cheating on Uncle Jesse have you guys
seen the key and peele bit where they
played a bunch of Cosby old Cosby Show
reruns at a defense trial for a cousin
it's [ __ ] great oh if I did not have
been in camp you know but oh my god as
well so you're saying you're getting
people mix-up
well every yeah a lot of comics look the
same person then they all come no wait
is it black I think it was an OG Simpson
sketch show actually oh yeah when he had
his sketch show it's all falling apart
huh hey just playing the bit just plain
the vet as usual yes dude I'm sure I'll
go down for this one
just don't run for public office Yeah
right I'll be screwed yeah oh yeah not
like my reputations ruined I'm going for
local dan I'm going for the big times
hey that's why you're a fan [ __ ]
extraordin yep yang is just setting it
up for me yang is like getting the
public ready for Asian president he's
getting wet for your dick the [ __ ]
slide ride all right yeah yeah come on
man Trump made it I made it
thank you what's I vote for Joe Oh see
that's the inspirational thing about
Trump if Trump can do it anyone can do
it it really is America yes we can yes
we can be a reality TV star and then a
President Reagan context context also
for context blastin we are blasted we're
preparing for a drunk
patreon special so if you guys want to
see that you should join our patron so
of course I thought thank you well those
a Simpson I'm blasted we had the
Terminator as the governor that's Carol
so why does inator the first YouTube
president be me why not have a whole
channel is full of reasons why yeah
how's that going have you seen it I
think it just started nice modulate with
Lily yeah I'm not trying to be a [ __ ]
TV host that shit's boring I'm just
saying people are making it okay cue I
was watching football the commercials
flat so how'd you feel about that I
really I really enjoyed it
I like the commercials for it and I was
like this is really good for all
youtubers this is good representation oh
man I gotta watch it now yeah I saw her
female rap it was cool I liked it it was
very for female rep it was her like
intro like opening for her show she raps
so she rapped this thing about like how
she's like breaking stereotypes a slice
she's like a woman and the late-night
thing I like talking about those like
breastfeeding moms and the thing I'm
like it was very like empowering looks
nice
was it funny it was empowering see it
wasn't funny couldn't stand that
bothered me too but cement the bees
funny who Samantha bee she's funny
full frontal I haven't seen her stuff
but I know she's funny it's not about
like I made me feel empowered whatever
it's a [ __ ] comedy show so I'm like
did it make you laugh though that's the
problem but they're not supposed to be
that funny they're supposed to be funny
enough and then they're definitely good
hosts know what I'm saying it is the
intention of the bit to get laughs or is
it to do this [ __ ] empowerment
[ __ ] what's a late-night show miss
Allison make your mouth go like this I'm
not even disputing that it's like Trevor
Noah isn't extremely funny but he makes
me go not even me not even me no no to
be a likeable person but I'm not I'm
just don't laugh at the show Jon Stewart
you used to [ __ ] blast my gun Jon
Stewart's a [ __ ] legend he's a legend
anyway we're talking about this though
what is this again Jake he's six more
Lachlan is going down that's all it is
good I mean I'm glad I'm glad that
they're getting a taste of them I want
her to be and Jane
going down shady price that's right no
it's a funnier or not funnier but
another funny thing about this story is
Lori Loughlin daughter yes Olivia I
think her name's Olivia Jade yeah Olivia
tape so she posted on her Instagram a
photo of her like flipping off and she
immediately took it down cuz there was
all these like what the [ __ ] are you
doing cuz it was after the sentencing of
this idiot I'm imagining her with her
parent with Lori and like her dad and be
like what the [ __ ] are you doing we're
literally under a microscope bad very
bad she took a picture like this yeah
there should flippin like birds she's
like mom do we go back that's when you
could beat the [ __ ] out of your kids
she's like oh no hey she needs an ass
beating though wait that's what you
could beat the [ __ ] out of that's not
you and she's like no that's not mean
Jesus I know we're both white but that's
not [ __ ] me oh sorry I thought those
were difficult like why would she post
that unless she thought it was about her
mom that's funny
well yeah but I get it I don't know
after I see you know if they're a part
of my childhood and I saw them on TV
they should be like national treasures
like I think enough has you know and
then we just kind of lured your parents
try to your child yeah well like we cage
them in a palace with an in their aura
tea on house arrest
that's what and they have to act
accordingly and then we just keep them
there like the princes like a beautiful
view like a beautiful peacock she was
that's an atrium and we're just gonna
keep them there and they can't move or
do anything and they have to play that
role well lady died moved it like 95
miles an hour
Princess Diana oh yeah yeah yeah pretty
fast see that's why we don't let them
out I never finish the story if you let
them out that's what happens I just know
she wasn't fast moving princess instead
of having a Museum of Wax we can have a
Museum of retired star exact real people
like so we can have called Vegas bro no
you
where celebrities go to die oh that's
the last stop when you think about
royalty in history right we're talking
about thousands of years of kings and
queens launch yet do you think that any
royalty ever moved as fast as crazy is
we randomly stumbled upon her site we
were just walking around and we're
looking at the Eiffel Tower
yeah well oh sure why they're all these
flowers and it was Princess Diana died
right underneath you mean a real man
Jesus Christ that was it really happen
yeah but I don't like to think about
that I was a kid he's going for the big
no it's really it was seriously like
[ __ ] no but did you ever see that
interview she did but she was talking
about that talk about that horse riding
[ __ ] helmet she's gone so fast I hate
you
I'm not laughing because I want to okay
please understand that you just really
look you trying to heighten the bit even
more this is look good to be in trouble
you're gonna get in trouble for getting
it higher who the only guy with a yes
who's gonna get mad at Steve for what
you'd be surprised
[ __ ] no I love what I know about
Elton John or you can be mad at me no
all right we'll see that that works I
don't know I like Hilton's listen we can
we can we could just end this
oh no but I would request that we leave
all in
[Music]